yeah welcome to this video playing
against caught crow Texan not the GM i'm
only getting GMC ax ya with 25 writing
you you steadily get grandmasters it's a
it's really tough to keep this rating
okay i'm playing a king's indian just
not just briefly checking grandmaster
kuya civic don't know them you don't
know him there's so many GM's ok so the
classical line let's see if we get
castles okay at least he's taking a bit
of time himself yeah i played this King
h8 lately night eh Shrivers the main
move but I don't know that at all back
then when I played the Kingston you're
not played 85 mostly this is completely
out of fashion nowadays maybe it isn't
great I don't know and I always apply
plate like that but I must admit that i
forgot lots of points about this yeah
he's five
hmm might see 59
hmm yeah this is all all coming very
quickly here this play
maybe maybe I did something something
wrong already I'm not shown a five is
not not terrible I mean but maybe I made
some inaccurate move can you take a take
on c7 even that then this is really a
inaccurate sir okay maybe he cannot okay
but I have a week before now slopped not
nice it is I immediately tried to to use
it so Bishop d7 and night see ADA try to
to keep this together okay it's not
exactly what I would I dreamt about oh
it just takes it surprising
okay so it's a kind of a keep it simple
approach but not bad of course rugby 7s
am a very serious an issue okay what is
mocha p8 is the sender than the the idea
to to to strengthen this will be 8 and 9
p-5 may be okay need to get a bit of
play cannot stay completely passive okay
taking a ridiculous maybe look f7 in
this position Rick f7 trying to exchange
it's not not great
not much fun this disposition by
thinking about Bishop e7 it's a
possibility keeping d6 covered of course
I can never play F for this would be
entirely really ridiculous maybe maybe I
can threaten a bitter like on f2 ok so
what is the story Nancy 76 but I can
take I can tag I can take and now and
now make Megan make a point of attack
only three we has got a weakness now
only three maybe I have some play the
iaf he needs to return this is a good
sign k Queen f6 is hanging
still Queen f6 Knight f3 twin f2 oh
forgot about that one I'm an idiot fire
yeah I've man i was back in the game and
then i gave it away i think k the sir
okay it takes with the porn i have c
form
and don't you never square can we have
seven eyes this Bishop e6 like this this
this but should be six no nice that's
really nice him and I don't have a check
or anything so where's this button yeah
yeah maybe I had at here at Wake hopes
of course it looks like I'm all played
here at it it looks like like bad for
black hoods it's still resilient and
here i thought yeah okay computer used
like a clear advantage we know the story
but here yeah it takes i can take on
edge 3m somehow it the somehow felt that
this this might be right but I
completely forgot about 94 simply on
Queen f6 I thought I simply didn't see
Nadia form let's say let's briefly check
the check if I take on age three yeah
well I had the idea but what's what's
the big difference that's no nighty for
what is this now this is a winning
straight winning what
what is the big difference
this what I saw just as a difficult game
queen bee three I can just take h3 and
Bishop e3 ah well impossible impossible
to see I mean not in a blitz game this
is the point here on this move I can I
can just take here and now there's this
coming okay this is just checked made
wow wow yeah this is the this is the
Kings Indian sometimes you get your
busted yeah here I'll plate you and then
you get this kind of one chance and you
need to grab this and then you win this
this weird games where you will you look
like look like a fool let's say you made
him Bishop age three yeah I think he may
be was a bit too here I can he can play
cautious moves their Bishop d3 or I
don't know small moves or Bishop d12 a
for this looks good also something like
this that this is yeah this is really
gives me this counter play and I'm
really better here it's fascinating the
move that Bishop f3 sm symbols
and then there's eform before yeah I
thought a sort of solidus not Wakely but
I saw this there it is dangerous is
taking of an h3 but I simply didn't see
94 at all so this is why I I went Queen
f6 I forgot about this move is
completely ok this was still on working
for me but here as it is it is very
tricky it takes he can't play Bishop g4
even but ok this is this is very very
bad h5 is the computer suggestion by ok
you bastard here and this is of course
nice and trapping the Queen can only go
here and then there should be six mob ok
yeah interesting game I had very little
chance at one point but probably am I
and black needs to play the opening
somewhat differently looks very
one-sided this kind of position looks
very one-sided ok thanks for watching